hey guys this is Penelope come with me
to the Lemmy event Penelope Disick knows
how to bring it on Tick Tock and now
she's going full-fledged blogger status
hey guys this is Penelope on Thursday
Kourtney Kardashian and Scott disick's
10 year old daughter took fans inside an
event for her famous mom's new gummy
vitamin and supplement line Lemmy which
featured a giant lip entrance and epic
dessert table a ball pit and some A-list
guests like court and her hubby Travis
Barker come with me to the lemon it was
so fun let me just tell you these are
all the desserts they were so good and
this is me my friend jumping in the ball
pit we had so much fun and then this is
a few of the people were there I just
asked someone to dance so yeah
this is my mom jumping in the ball pit
extra points for P's cute pun promoting
the family business come with me to the
Lemmy event it was so fun let me just
tell you the Vlog was shared to the
poosh founder and her little girl's
joint account titled pea and Court I'm
just like living life the mommy daughter
Duo joined the social media platform
together last year
[Music]
and they've been bringing grade A
content ever since
the two have treated fans to Beauty
tutorials home tours and some seriously
yummy campfire moments
[Music]
P's dad Scott has gotten in on the fun
too
so has P's stepdad
[Music]
in fact court and Penelope have so much
fun on Tick Tock that shortly after they
launched their joint account he's cousin
North and her mom Kim Kardashian
followed suit why not
oh best friend we can no no friends
but get this they've actually been
making Tick Tock secretly since 2020.
North has a private Tick Tock account so
we we do uh lots of tick tocks together
and she puts them in drafts yeah she's
not allowed to post them but we have
lots of tick tocks I might post one soon
and ever since the skims founder and her
kiddo went public on the platform
they've shared some quality vids too
it's really lit and fun and crazy Holy
Spirit activate activate activate I
don't know how you're gonna top that Kim
even dances
[Music]
please help me baby even though she
famously claims she doesn't Dance I'm
like a notorious non-dancer like it's a
thing of course it's no surprise the
Kardashians slay a social media moment
you know social media is such a great
tool he and North already have millions
of followers on Tick Tock and Kim has
some Sage words of wisdom about sharing
life online that might just come in
handy for the girls someday just don't
be impulsive think it through think
about if you want people to know this
information because it'll always be
there and that will never change you
need boundaries and to quote Penelope
North's Grandma Kris Jenner so far
they're doing amazing you're doing
amazing
[Music]